the series finale for Game of Thrones
has finally aired and that means
spoilers are flying everywhere
including here but for one person in
particular being able to discuss the
ending of Game of Thrones is a massive
relief Isaac M stead writes has revealed
that he's been waiting for months to
crow to the world that his character
bran stark shockingly ended up as ruler
of Westeros as he enthusiastically put
it to Entertainment Weekly quote I just
want to shout King mother as of course
Game of Thrones is a series famous for
its twists having shocked fans before
were scenes like the red wedding
the gruesome battle between Prince
Oberyn Martell and the mountain Jon
Snow's impermanent death
the haunting sacrifice of Shireen
Baratheon by our own parents and many
more but that didn't prepare hemstead
right for the reality of from becoming
King in fact when he first read the
script for the finale
he thought the scene where the gathered
Nobles of Westeros are like bran king
was actually an elaborate prank when I
got to the dragon pit scene in the last
episode and they're like what about bran
I had to get up and pace around the room
I genuinely thought it was a joke script
a calling to the actor his first source
upon reading the script was that
showrunners David Benioff and DB Weiss
had sent each cast member a script with
their own character ending up on the
Iron Throne once he realized that Game
of Thrones really would end with the
North becoming his own independent
Kingdom and the so called ran the broken
rising as a ruler of the remaining six
kingdoms Hempstead right got to thinking
about whether it all made sense and from
the actors perspective he feels Brown is
a fantastic fit for the job bran may not
be strictly human anymore given his
otherworldly status as he unemotional
three-eyed Raven but his psychic
omniscience and separation from the
petty squabbles of his fellow man is
also beneficial letting him potentially
keep Westeros safe like no one else can
he's all logic and reason without the
dangerous emotions are led to the
disastrous rains of previous terrible
monarchs like King Robert King Joffrey
Queen Cersei and Queen Daenerys hemstead
writes said I think will be a really
good King actually perhaps there will be
something missing and having a real
emotive leader which is a useful quality
in a king or queen as well at the same
time you can't really argue with bran
he's like no I know everything the actor
assured fans that despite his initial
shock he's happy with the way the
Thrones finale worked out but he did
share his thoughts about an alternate
conclusion you might have enjoyed even
more thinking about other ways a series
ending could have gone hemstead right
shared
did one to die and get in one good def
scene with an exploding head or
something
it's a relatable desire but come on no
one can beat the Viper in that
department of course not everyone is
happy with bran becoming King
all the events that led up to it like
John killing Daenerys after the finale
aired on May 19th fans flocked to social
media to vent their outrage and
frustration which is after all the
primary use of social media even Thrones
actors themselves have expressed
frustration with how the series ended
though most of those gripes centered
more on each star's respective character
arcs and less on the larger picture are
you happy with how things ended when all
is said and done though Hempstead right
is confident that the ending of Game of
Thrones as shocking and polarizing as it
is is exactly how a Song of Ice and Fire
author george RR martin would have drawn
the story to a close if he had gotten
there first speaking before the finale
aired the actor she had a prediction
about the family action that turned out
to be correct
saying not everyone will be happy I
don't think anybody will think it's
predictable and that's as much as you
can hope for people are going to be
angry there's going to be a lot of
broken hearts it's bittersweet exactly
as george RR martin intended it's a
fitting conclusion to this epic saga
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel answer
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]